en el último vídeo analizamos una
función e intentamos dibujar su derivada
y en este vídeo veremos una función e
intentaremos dibujar su anti derivada y
su anti derivada parece ser una palabra
am como que media elegante pero pero la
anti derivada de una función es una
función cuya derivada es esa función por
ejemplo tenemos aquí a fx y digamos que
la anti derivada de fx la anti derivada
de fx es f mayúscula de x ésta tiende a
hacer la anotación cuando estamos
hablando de la anti derivada esto
simplemente significa que la derivada de
f mayúscula de x lo cual es igual a efe
mayúscula prima de x es igual a efe x lo
que intentaremos hacer aquí tú puedes
ver que tenemos nuestra fx y vamos a
pensar cuál es una posible función de la
cual ésta pueda hacer su derivada esto
lo puedes lo vas a estudiar con más
detalle
cálculo integral pero hay varias
funciones de la cual ésta podría ser su
derivada y nuestra meta en este vídeo es
dibujar una posibilidad razonable
entonces pensemos en ello un poco acá
tenemos a y es igual a efe mayúscula de
x lo que intentaremos hacer aquí es
dibujar una función donde su derivada
pueda verse así y lo que hacemos es
decir de lo que tenemos acá a esto
tomando su derivada entonces pensemos en
cómo podría ver si una función cuando
vemos su derivada cuando vemos su
derivada dice que en el primer intervalo
en este primer intervalo lo voy a hacer
en morado es este intervalo desde x
igual a 0 hasta llegar al valor
cualquiera que sea este de acá arriba
nos dice que la pendiente es una
constante positiva de valor 1 entonces
voy a dibujar una línea con una
pendiente de constante positiva 1 y yo
podría desplazar esta línea hacia arriba
o hacia abajo porque hay muchas anti
derivadas posibles simplemente voy a
elegir la que mejor me convenga
entonces yo podría tener una línea que
se mira
algo así lo que intento hacer es dibujar
una línea con pendiente positiva 1 lo
mejor que pueda entonces se ve así y yo
podría hacer que la función esté
definida o no la derivada no está
definida en ese punto sin embargo yo
puedo dejar mi línea definida o
indefinida como mejor me parezca esto
tal vez sea un punto de discontinuidad
en la función original no tiene por qué
serlo simplemente yo intento dibujar una
posible función entonces digamos que si
está definido en ese punto pero como
esto va a ser discontinuo la derivada
estará indefinida en ese punto y ahí
tenemos nuestro primer intervalo ahora
veamos el segundo intervalo el intervalo
que inicia dónde termina el primero
hasta llegar más o menos aquí como
puedes ver la derivada es una constante
negativa de menos 2 entonces eso quiere
decir que acá arriba tendrá una línea
una pendiente constante de valor menos 2
tendrá el doble de declive que la
función anterior yo podría simplemente
hacer una función continua
parece que este intervalo tiene la mitad
de longitud que este otro intervalo de
aquí está más o menos parece eso no
podría yo simplemente dibujar una línea
con pendiente de menos 2 entonces se
miraría algo así lo voy a hacer un poco
mejor esté aquí de aquí acá se mirarían
algo así y ahora bien esta línea tiene
una pendiente de 1 lo podemos ver en su
derivada aquí lo ves y esta otra línea
tiene una pendiente de menos 2
pendiente de -2 también lo podemos ver
en su derivada ahora aquí se pone la
cosa interesante yo podría trasladar
esta línea hacia arriba o abajo no tiene
por qué ser una función continua pero lo
hago por por divertirme ahora aquí hay
muchas posibles anti derivadas de esta
función muy bien entonces qué sucede en
el siguiente intervalo que sucede aquí
lo voy a hacer en naranja la pendiente
inicia en un valor alto en dos positivos
pero después decrece hasta llegar a cero
aquí está el cero entonces acá está cero
y después se hace más y más y más y más
negativa entonces intentaré hacer una
función continua no tiene por qué ser
continua simplemente lo hago por
diversión así que aquí la pendiente es
positiva es de 2 positivo será una línea
con pendiente positiva 2 lo contrario a
la anterior la otra era de menos 2 luego
se hace cada vez menos y menos positiva
aún aquí es positiva
llegar a 0 y donde es 0 más o menos será
más o menos por aquí supongo ajá por
aquí entonces lo que tendremos es como
una parábola una parábola hacia abajo
nótese que la pendiente tiene un valor
positivo aquí tiene pendiente 2 luego se
hace menos y menos y menos positiva
hasta llegar al 0 después de pendiente
se hace negativa entonces nuestra
función se mirará algo así sobre el
intervalo de hecho no me gustó porque
porque bueno lo haré un poco mejor
porque nótese que bueno esta función es
simétrica cierto entonces nuestra curva
se mirará am también debe ser simétrica
entonces se mirarán a algo así y
finalmente el último intervalo vamos con
el último aunque parece el que sigue
indefinidamente entonces bueno tiene
pendiente 0 no tengo por qué dibujar una
función continua pero cuando la
pendiente 0
eso quiere decir que tengo una línea con
pendiente 0 tengo una línea horizontal
podría dibujar esa línea horizontal aquí
arriba entonces podría yo decir que es
discontinua o podría dibujarla también
aquí acá abajo y tratar de hacer una
tratar de hacer que mi anti derivada sea
una función continua
una vez más yo podría desplazar
cualquiera de estos segmentos hacia
arriba o hacia abajo hubiera obtenido la
misma derivada pero no tendría una
función continua como esta es cierto
pero tuvimos éxito porque construimos
una a una posible anti derivada para fx
ahora como recordatorio la anti derivada
es una función donde f x podría ser su
derivada